but guys forcing all the social media
Instagram Twitter Facebook Francisca
Foster constant kissing trigger pod
follow us all that's on kill it already
come on follow us follow us follow us
hello beautiful bigots bigger tessas the
cute little bigger teeny and of course
the entire bigot ex Community welcome
well welcome all it is the first raw of
the week Francis it is the first world
of the week welcome one Welcome All We
have got so much good news all positive
stories from across the globe Francis
I'm sorry you're wrong what would you
mean it's not accurate what you say we
haven't got great stories from around
the world there's only one story
happening in the world right now is it
about Russia in
Nori no all right
all right is it about the U.S
instability political instability in the
U.S no is it about Elon Musk no I know
what you're thinking it's about China
yeah is yes the locked anti-lockdown
price how could I forget no is it
so what is it about yeah you're probably
thinking we did a great interview with
Ali Ansari about Iran is it that oh yes
yes the brave protesters standing up for
women's rights in what is an Undisputed
great moment for feminism and the
feminist movement yeah
it's not that mate so yeah you you could
be thinking it's the fact that people
are so poor in some parts of the UK
they're resorting to eating pet food
yeah yeah it's not that it's not that
it's not the fact that the economy is
going down the toilet no so what is it
well
I don't know how to say this Francis
this will be a shock to both you and our
audience yeah
a woman who is Black yeah went to a
reception yeah and there was another
woman there who asked her impolitely and
in a quite pushy way where she's really
from all right and that has been front
page news on the BBC News website for
the last two days I mean well that to be
honest review is worse than the fact
that everybody's going to be in Pet Food
in about two weeks
I never thought I'd hear you say that
mate I thought I thought you'd be pretty
interesting on the healthy food on the
man food but uh yes Francis so uh what
happened was there was a lady yeah uh a
black lady yes a lady of color a lady of
color they're disgusting bigot yeah and
uh she went well and in fact Anton is
finished bringing us the hats that we
forgot to bring yeah uh so why don't we
go to the first story Anton and have a
read about the facts because we've got
to get the facts right because in the
story of this magnitude you've got to be
precise you can't go a step wrong have a
look at this it needs to be like a legal
[ __ ] document let's have a look
William's godmother ladies Lady Susan
Hussey she sounds like she's in a porn
I'm mine resigns over racism real well
Kensington police calls Kensington
police mate Kensington Palace it should
be the case it should be locked up you
should be [ __ ] locked up for asking
where someone's really from you
disgusting Nazi
I reckon I can get a job on Navara media
you definitely could look at that look
at the face of bigotry yeah ah slice of
prime Posh Gammon right there yeah
absolute mate she's never met someone
with your accent in her entire life
she's William's godmother yeah anyway
keeps crawling look at that massive
racist yeah in the burn the Prince of
Wales is official spokesman has said
that racism has no place in our society
nor do people who are 83 years old who
make a mistake after William's godmother
resigned from the Royal household for
asking a Charity's black chief executive
where she really came from uh the
domestic abuse campaigner ngozi philani
the typical British Name by the way
exactly was attending a reception hosted
by the queen on Tuesday at Buckingham
Palace to Mark the United Nations 16
days of activism
[ __ ] mate against gender-based violence
Fulani said Lady Susan Hussey 83 brushed
her hair aside to read her name badge
and began questioning her about which
part of Africa she came from I'm sure it
was delivered in that time uh when
Fulani told us she was from Hackney in
North London she says hussy who was Lady
and waiting to the late Queen and made
Lady of
lady replied no but when do you really
come from that is exactly the accent
that would have been where do your
people come from when did you first come
here and why and why were you allowed
hmm
the second part was made up for me there
she there she is a spokesman that's lady
Hussey right there yeah a spokesman for
Kensington Palace said I was really
disappointed to hear about the guest
experience in Buckingham Palace last
night racism has no place in our society
the comments were unacceptable and it is
right that the individual has stepped
aside with a meat they can't even bring
themselves to name her yeah and it is
right that the individual has been
executed with immediate effect excellent
uh the rebrandts were written by the
Prince of Wales official spokesman but
discussed with William before he got on
a plane for the U.S he thinks a course
of action taken is correct a palace saw
said the route threatens to overshadow
William and Kate's trip to how how does
it threaten to overshadow the trip to
Boston
I just like because a woman asked a
slightly inappropriate question an old
woman an 83 year old woman of course
she's [ __ ] tackless she's 83. when
was the last time you met an 83 year old
who didn't say something vaguely
inappropriate and the thing is she kept
repeating the question she's probably
got dementia she was just going over and
over the same thing because she couldn't
remember what the answer was so really
they've done a favor by getting rid of
her because she was just clogging the
place up anyway Where They will announce
the winners of the earth shot
environmental Awards in mentioning
racism uh the princess spokesman went
further than Buckingham Palace which to
referred to unacceptable and deeply
regrettable comments a palace spokesman
said we have reached out to ngazi Fulani
and are invited to find out where she's
really from to find out where the bloody
hell she's from you know and to see if
it's Bongo Bongo land anyway you know
inviting her to discuss all elements of
her experience in person if she wishes
there we go um in the meantime the
individual concern would like to express
up why do they keep calling her the
individual because she doesn't deserve a
name
that's what happens to racist not name
and name and James anymore we're gonna
defucking name them they're just going
to be known as individuals the
individual concern would like to express
our profound apologies for the hurt
cause and has stepped aside from her
name with a media effect yes all members
of the household are being reminded of
diversity and inclusivity policies which
they're required to [ __ ] young
story this [ __ ] story I can't I can't
do this with a straight face yeah
Fulani is the chief executive of sister
space a charity that supports women of
African and Caribbean Heritage of
African well I thought
well I thought you're not supposed to
talk about where you're from yeah or
where your ancestry is from yeah
she's an African
okay anyway sorry carry on who face
domestic abuse she called The Exchange a
violation
she also called it abuse as well but
since she been sorry until mate scroll
down but since you would be willing to
speak to the Palace to bring about
positive solution [ __ ] means this is a
problem Viva La wrote it out love this
is an inappropriate question you got
it's not the [ __ ] Middle East of
positive solution what do you want
[ __ ] reparations I bet she does mate
anyway crack on crying on Twitter felony
said she told her lady I'm a British
national my parents came here in the 50s
to which their aid is alleged to have
said I knew we'd get there in the end
your Caribbean
there we go scroll down it turns out she
wasn't Caribbean The Exchange ended with
Fulani saying no lady I am of African
Heritage Caribbean descent
what
and British nationality yeah but so what
she is Caribbean she's been a dick yeah
because black people in the Caribbean
are descended from Africa we all
understand that yeah so she she is
Caribbean yeah so she's Caribbean yeah
she's got an African name though yeah
where's she really from me I don't know
mate I think you should go I think you
should go and ask him well I'd love to
ask her but no one in the story mentions
it where is she really from yeah where'd
you [ __ ] come from tell me
someone in the chances yeah carry on the
queen gave a speech at the event for 300
people in which she spoke about the
global pandemic of violence against
women our guests include Alona zelenska
the wife of the Ukrainian president
queen matild Matilda I'd imagine of
Belgium yeah Quinn Ryan Quinn run is
actually very cool do you know her she's
a really inspiring woman Queen Reynold
Jordan and you'd like her yeah she's
quite fit and Crown Princess Mary of
Denmark no you can't have a Crown
Princess Mary you need to speak you
can't so I'm having a Crown Princess
Stacy it doesn't [ __ ] work anyway
Fulani said that following the incident
the rest of the reception was a blah
she's talking about like it was a
near-death experience
[ __ ] my life there was nobody to report
it to I couldn't report it to the
Queen's concert plus it was such a shock
to me and the other two women that we
were stunned into temporary silence
thankfully they had a Twitter account
yeah they managed to tweet about it
despite being stunned into silence I
just stood at the edge of the room
smiled and engaged briefly with with who
spoke to me until I could leave my
children and grandchildren were proud
though in my parents time black people
were only allowed into those spaces to
serve kind of glad my folks went all
around the witnesses violation listen
love I think your [ __ ] grandparents
and your parents went through a lot more
[ __ ] than having somebody ask them where
they're really from well she's made some
right conclusions anyway because I let
my guard down never again it was such a
struggle to stay in the space that you
were why
she's talking about like she's been
raped mate yeah
I think it's essential to acknowledge
that trauma has occurred and being
invited and then insulted has caused
much damage what listen what's wrong
acknowledge that there's been [ __ ]
trauma what what trauma what do you mean
you've got to ask what I get asked where
I'm from every [ __ ] day yeah but
you're not acknowledging your trauma
acknowledgment I'm so angry all the time
yes I'm repressed yeah exactly it's
because you you've been you've just been
inflicted with millions of little
microaggressions and that's why you're
going around like that Anton would you
mind that as just an experiment uh would
you open the BBC home page uh just the
actual BBC homepage I want to see if
it's still the top story it's been good
it should be it's been the top story for
two days now this is a disgusting
example of the rise of the third rank
they're coming back and it's 83 year old
women asking people where they're really
we're going to talk more about this so
uh is this welcome to the BBC so keep
going so that's the first story Palace
race incident was abuse says charity
boss uh and then Russia uses a dud
nuclear missile capable of being nuclear
that's like further down
um
okay British AIDS activist yeah good so
it's still top story basically we've
established that Anton would you pull up
my sub stack now I want to show people
the whole thing in context how it was
being covered it's basically been
covered like a terrorist attack man so
it should be it is a [ __ ] terrorist
attack
so Anton scroll down to this yeah and
make this big if you can
are you able to yeah so look at that the
first story is Palace race incident was
abused says charity boss yeah the second
story is William and Kate in Boston
after race Rao yeah good they had
nothing to do with yeah but it's a
Fallout mate this is a big story it's a
big deal it is echoing around the world
you know they're talking about this in
ukrime I'm sure they are I know Anton
pull it back up because I want to talk
about the other stories uh the third
story is obviously not as important is
the fact that in Britain in 2022 uh
people wait for up to 40 hours for an
ambulance it's not that's not important
no next door is house prices have four
biggest fall in two years who cares no
one can have four of them next story is
a person of color by the way a rugby
player has been missing for weeks well
you know what he's got male privilege
and then very much in the top right
corner there there's a story about the
fact that uh basically people in Wales
are eating pet food because they can't
afford real food I mean they've never
been able to afford food anyway so it's
fine yeah so there you go and if you're
tuning in from from around the world and
wondering what the [ __ ] are those
British people up to this is what we do
now that is what our societies become we
talk about the fact that someone was
slightly inconsiderate to someone else
for days because brace was involved yeah
and so we should these are the big
issues that we're going to talk about
more on this show let's bring up this
article we've got another 10 articles
have we got more ten we've got 10
articles have we yeah we've got 10
articles because this is what this story
deserves in the meantime tell us what
you think send us a PayPal send us a
super chat we'll read them all out in a
minute but for answers but before we go
mate Tony uh we've got an actual video
clip of the the victim okay let's go
talking the victim has got to be heard
the victims need to be heard you didn't
expect the fury have you had any
response directly from back in Paris we
understand Prince William has invited
you no so that surprised me people keep
saying the palace has reached out to me
nobody's reached out to me no from the
palace they reached out to the charity
no no
no I don't I don't know
where this has come from but I'm telling
you categorically we have not heard from
the palace so the Prince of Wales Prince
William made a statement saying he was
inviting you to the Palace to discuss
all elements of your experience will you
take up that invitation see what we're
about is
positive results
so absolutely I think a discussion
should be held and we're very happy to
have that discussion because we just
want to bring it back to the 16 days of
activism this is about violence against
women and girls and although I didn't
experience physical violence what I feel
I experience was a form of abuse I think
it's important as well that we look at
this holistically and so when all of
this blows over what changes have been
made so when we talk about going back to
the Palace or when we talk about having
meetings and having these important
conversations to ensure that this
structure this whole
infrastructure that allowed such
Behavior to take place has been rerouted
there's a revamp in education there's
been a there's been a swift reaction
from the palace once they realized what
had happened uh lady hussy has stepped
down as well is that something that you
welcome
I I think how the palace handles that
situation is between the palace and the
person now I I have to make clear it
wasn't my intention that her name should
be out there I just used initials
because I personally she's an elder I
and we respect the elders in our
community and I do not want anything to
happen to her in terms of people
hounding her and what will that solve
nothing so why can't we get something
positive out of this we have to talk
about that issue of race
because it's in so many institutions
you know the people that want to say you
know she was 83 and all this that's kind
of ageism don't assume that because
somebody's a certain age that they don't
have the ability I took time during that
whole trauma to make sure that
she seems to be okay this isn't a case
of maybe she couldn't hear me that's why
she asked me seven or eight times I did
what I could to make sure that this is
what it appears to be and I I have
Clarity that was racism I think we all
there you go mate yeah uh so she didn't
experience physical violence but nope
stupid yeah being asked the wrong
question a few times it's abuse [ __ ]
abuse me yeah exactly and she doesn't
want anything to happen to her yeah
because she's all about the Positive
Solutions exactly because they're
looking at the problem holistically yeah
they are uh and the holistic point I
think here is her charity needs more
money exactly and attention I know
I mean I'm being a bit cynical there may
you know yeah but she didn't want a
doctor either so that's why she just
used her initials yeah instead of
keeping it absolutely not have actually
tweeted that uh she wanted her identity
to be kept private yeah after
publicly saying that this person's
initials were this yeah because that's
what you do when you want to keep
someone's identity private you first of
all release their initials into the
public sphere and then say keep it
private Anton if you still got my sub
stack open by the way uh could you go
down there is another there's a
screenshot of a tweet from this uh
charity that I want you to see uh myself
a second guys read read this piece I'm
very proud of it it's actually a pretty
good piece on my sub stack about this
issue but I want to show you Francis a
tweet from this uh charity from last
year just to give you a bit of context
so our charity supports black women
domestic violence survivors [ __ ] the
white [ __ ] yep um I can't stay silent
about this I admire Megan for speaking
out according to clear definition it
seems Megan is a survivor of domestic
violence from her in-laws that would be
King Charles and Camilla yeah I am glad
hypocrite peers left ITV uh and it
concludes there so uh Meghan Markle you
and you're a big fan yeah absolutely
well she's the victim of domestic
violence from King Charles there we go
so anyway uh that's where to be fair she
can [ __ ] dick him who Megan
he's like he's had all his child she's
about 80. mate don't don't project your
dreams and aspirations onto King yeah
you can [ __ ] dick me anytime Megan
yeah love it um so but look Francis
basically I read the transcript and the
transcript is basically this the lady
husky says where are you from this woman
says I'm from Hackney she says no no
were you really from she says I'm
British and blah blah blah and you know
it's an uncomfortable and somewhat
unpleasant thing to say to somebody who
who has a different skin tone because it
sort of implies that they're not really
British blah blah blah for someone who
was born in this country that can be
unpleasant now I I mean In fairness tune
goes you like me she has a very foreign
sounding name yeah and she should leave
correct I'm sure you believe that but
she also is always dressed in African
looking clothing yeah as she was in that
video clip that we played yeah is it
unreasonable for people into that
situation to want to find out about her
Heritage yeah I don't think it is but
more importantly than that I've been
asked that question loads of times
usually very sensitively not quite in
the brunt blunt and perhaps price
Commander that happened in this case but
this woman I [ __ ] guarantee you yeah
because in every conversation both
parties have a role to play yeah she
could have just said look I know what
you're asking me you're trying to find
out where my Heritage is from yeah I was
born in the UK I grew up in Hackney my
family are from blah blah blah my dad's
from blah blah blah my mom's from blah
blah and they could have it and the
other woman would have gone oh that's
really interesting and they would have
had a nice conversation but if you have
this activist mindset yeah you create
create these situations and she's like
oh I can't believe she's been canceled
anyway positive outcome from my charity
please yeah exactly this is and look you
know what in gozi I don't remember her
surname
[ __ ] race yeah she's perfectly
entitled to have her opinions and to be
an activist and to I'm sure her charity
does great work right that's fine but
the [ __ ] media what are you doing
this is a non-story no they're not
they're rooting out systemic racism
within the royal family they're rooting
out systemic racism from 183 year old
grandmother exactly gonna [ __ ] beat
it either so she's never gonna do it
again because that's the only way the
old Pricks are going to learn he's never
going to do it again because he's gonna
die exactly probably quite soon yeah and
then that Society will be less racist
it's [ __ ] clown world [ __ ] off back
to Karachi cake exactly I've still got
my makeup on from the interview earlier
yeah it's
what is how is this a front page news
story for two days
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
can you imagine trying to explain this I
bet you there is not a person in Africa
who can get their story around this head
around this [ __ ] story
they're sitting there going what the
[ __ ] is wrong with those people in
Britain
I think it needs talking about
I think it's your white privilege mate
yeah my brown privilege at this point
yeah [ __ ] hell more orange eggs how
how are we how is this a story
it's a story because it's talking about
abuse well the thing is Francis if she
genuinely felt that she'd been abused
surely the thing to do would be to you
know in her case go home whatever
complain about it privately afterwards
get a private apology which I'm sure
would have been forthcoming and that
would be the matter dealt with no I
think it's called to get the police
involved mate let's [ __ ] escalate I
bet you will get the police involved yes
I hate speech exactly they're going to
come into the palace there's going to be
someone getting shanked outside but that
doesn't matter what matters is that we
deal with the [ __ ] questions an 83
year old woman asked
you know what we need we've got all
these hats for all these different
accents that we did you know what how we
need well a clown hat yeah and we just
should be wearing it we should just have
a permanent clown hat behind us yeah
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this country
how is this a a front page story for two
days
because it involves explain it to me it
involves abuse it involves systemic
racism it involves a violation
it involves
holistic healing
it involves Anton shout out to me I'll
say what else is there we're running out
of buzzwords man yeah it's it just
involves a lot of people getting upset
about something that's not worth getting
upset about and it's it involves
you know some kind of rep you know some
kind of reparation there we go involves
all of that
mate
what's going on
it do you I sometimes wonder if they
whoever they are and in my case it can't
be the Jews otherwise I'd be complicit
right whoever is running the world yeah
right and it's not my boys unfortunately
do you think they're sometimes just
sitting there going let's see how we can
[ __ ] with these pricks
let's see if we stick a non-story about
a non-issue on the front page of every
[ __ ] newspaper for two days and
they'll just not say anything I was
joking there's a flaw to your argument
because I'm hoping to hear it okay you
think it's a non-issue as does everybody
else they don't think it's a non-issue
who's they the people running the papers
it sounded like Kanye here man yeah
exactly
who's there [ __ ] do it I'm just going
to turn up yeah with a [ __ ] sock on
my head anyway no but the the people who
run the media the commentariat class
believe this is actually a big deal why
because they have drunk the [ __ ]
Kool-Aid they see racism everywhere they
see the fact that you know everything is
systemically racist you know diversity
inclusion Equity okay I let's say for
the sake of argument I accept that yeah
and this is an example of somebody being
racist yeah
is that the worst thing that's happened
today
subjective what do you mean subjective
there are people being murdered right
now yeah
but they're not victim of systemic
racism no but they're being murdered
yeah there are people starving to death
yeah they're people pensioners in this
country freezing to death exactly
Vladimir Putin has just launched a
weapon that could be used as a nuke yeah
Chinese protesters have got Xi Jinping
to back down the people in Iran are
being beaten to death for protesting
about their rights yeah
yeah but they weren't made to feel
slightly uncomfortable in the palace
were they what is wrong with
look I know there is one Guardian
journalist watching this writing
everything down for their [ __ ]
little article about how we can't use
[ __ ] we got in trouble last time
yeah [ __ ] little article yeah right
about how whatever right what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you
examine your life
look at yourself look in the mirror and
wake up and go I am writing a piece
today about a woman who was slightly
unpleasant to another woman
examine Your Privilege and that is going
to be the front page headline and so it
should be
it's only by meeting racism head-on can
we absolutely defeat it and then we just
go on and Target other old women and
[ __ ] beat them into the ground and
destroy their reputation publicly and
get them to lose their jobs
that's how we're going to defeat racism
by crushing one granny at a time
my this is unbelievable that was a bit
of a Martin Luther King speech by the
way yeah it was very inspiring don't
forget Martin Luther King's idea of
everyone trying to avoid thinking too
much about each other's skin color is
racist now exactly he's a coconut mate
as they would say yeah now he was all
about [ __ ] beating up grannies mate
in order to achieve Equity that's how
you get social justice yeah and
inclusion yeah you take an 83 year old
and you just you know destroy a
reputation over one comment that you
could have completely navigated your way
around yeah and not even made it a thing
and then they leaked it to the press
That's What Simmons come on mate that's
not fair just leak it to the Press no
she just put her initial she just
tweeted about it anyway let's find I'm
sure you're all on board with all of
this and regarding let's find out what
all the bigots are saying yeah uh Kim
Jong-un
if you go for a job interview and then
and in the toilets that is a sign this
is professional workplace please do not
defecate on floor what do I do
stuff again in the toilet yeah
I don't know what you do in North Korea
mate yeah but it's not [ __ ] natural
and you're in England mate [ __ ] obey
the rules Mr Steve or the five I I feel
like you need uh the Gammon camera
[ __ ] right let's see right okay what
are we talking about men who have sex
with men at least you might the word for
it is gay all right guys there's nothing
wrong with being gay or if you're being
technical homosexual all right
uh actually uh men who have sex with men
is uh they use it not to avoid saying
gay but uh there's a reason for I used
to translate a lot of uh documents for
the global fund to fight AIDS
tuberculosis and malaria and the reason
they use men who have sex with men is
that in a lot of countries
you know like Qatar we've talked about
this quite a bit recently being gay
isn't really allowed I mean having sex
with men also isn't allowed but like a
lot of people who are gay or who at
least have sex with men men who have sex
with men don't want to identify as gay
because it makes them unsafe and
whatever so that's why they use it so
it's like [ __ ]
foreign
says You must respect my Heritage and
you must not know or ask about my
Heritage exactly well said mate that is
correct you win yeah
uh hyper focus with a two knicker slow
traffic on the A35 Bournemouth well mate
that is the most exciting story I've
come across today I'm not gonna lie yeah
well done
Inspector Clouseau oh well let's get to
find choices
where you perform foreigners
well you're not a foreigner no wait wait
wait no you were born here yeah I was
born here yeah but you're not you're not
actually British are you I'm not well
were you really from me where am I
really from well my family's from well
my mom's family's from Venezuela but a
lot of them were you know Arabs might
they're from Lebanon only your nose is
Arabic or Jewish yeah same thing really
uh where's your face from no my face sir
yeah this isn't Our advice
I have never seen an Arab who looks like
Louis Theroux mate listen you put a
[ __ ] dog skin on me mate I look like
a [ __ ] Arab mate you've put dark skin
on you when you put too much makeup on
one day you didn't look like an Arab
listen the reason you look like Louis
the cross between Luther and Donald
Trump exactly both great men
having said that right that's why I look
Jewish right because Jews and Arabs are
one of the same [ __ ] people you can't
say that because they kick off you know
they like doing that around that part
but anyway thank you very much Eric
you'll go oh my god with the ten dollars
uh
[ __ ]
if you like to speak with a non-delicate
POC libertarian artist and YouTuber Eric
July has made over three million dollars
and selling non-wood comic non-woke
comic books would you interview him
Anton would you make a note that sounds
like a really good conversation yeah I'd
love to yeah uh e to the B to the L on
the paypalio sent us 20 quid and she
says I grew up during the 70s and 80s in
a town where the national front a
genuine and this is for people from
abroad they were a genuinely racist and
violent organization like they were
[ __ ] terrifying those boys uh
especially for Arabs like um we're
active and our black and Asian neighbors
faced real attacks and abuse I can
understand her being offended at this
old bird making a clumsy inquiry but I
do wonder how this ends up negatively
impacting the response to actual racism
if everything is assault or abuse then
eventually nothing is well of course and
this is another thing that people
haven't talked about think of the the
affect this hands on relations between
people of different ethnicity to meet
each other they are now worried about
the way they ask a question or whatever
right gone you've got a CR you've got a
did you never tell you the word I can
see you've got a dick joke in your head
get it out exactly no I can't do that
mate not after you know if what happened
last time
however now I told you oh I met poem
didn't I
because I because I mean there is a
version on the story you probably don't
want me to tell on the stream but anyway
yeah so I I was teaching a comedy course
and she came in to sign pooping is his
girlfriend by the way for those of you
yeah but but person of color we don't
assume she is of color yeah yeah and uh
asked her name and she she had a Latin
American name yeah and I'll go to it
well where are you from and she goes
New York I go no no but where are you
really from and she just looked at me
and she no no no no no no no no no but
whereabouts and she was like oh here and
I'm like no no no no no but like where
do your family come from and she gave me
the stink eye yeah and she goes are you
asking either you've since got used to
yeah exactly yeah I see a [ __ ] lot
mate and then she goes oh you ask me
where I'm really from and I and I went
in Spanish yes where are you really from
and then she told me so who won
the racism exactly see look
Lads if you want to pick yourself up a
nice brown girl like Francis yeah all
you got to do is ask her where she's
really from yeah exactly and when she
queries your racism double down maybe
that's what a lady Hussey was doing she
felt a bit lesbian in her old age and
she was trying to chat this bird up
listen do a trump double down don't
apologize
do it but anyway ebl makes a good point
because my point is think about this
like people in positions of of a similar
nature
because all she was trying to get at is
what is your ancestry a question that we
all want to know about each other when
we meet each other it's one of the first
things people always talk about you know
this we talk about it on the show my
ethnicity your ethnicity yeah it's what
people are interested in about each
other it's a healthy curiosity badly
worded in this case admittedly right but
she didn't mean any harm but unless
unless what we're trying to say here is
ladyhasi was deliberately trying to make
this belittle this person by asking
where she's from yeah I don't think she
was no
unlike you and pumpkin exactly anyway
crack on
Fox here with a fiver crazy that this
has been the headline on BBC for two
full days it's a scout for the righteous
if in Goldie sorry
feels uh that that that that was trauma
what she in what she sorry in the
involved in violence for why is she
involved in a domestic violence charity
there we go well look I think a lot of
people who work on stuff like that they
get you know
there might be a [ __ ] hard job let's
be honest
I I've never done it might be a piece of
piss oh yeah I mean you don't know until
you tried it yeah exactly it could just
be pushing a bit of paper around yeah I
mean exactly all right building this
pile but anyway yeah I think we've gone
too far yeah I was going to go further
and I'm right yeah we're probably in
dangerous territory I probably are a
little bit anyway but anyway next
reverse out of that cold is saying yeah
[Music]
anyway my my point is um
people in in that line of work they tend
to be very sensitive and they tend to
have experienced trauma themselves
genuine trauma and abuse and the
definitions can expand right I
understand if she feels that way I mean
I think she's wrong that's not what
abuse and violence mean however the
media have gone the media have a
responsibility Jack actually know the
meanings of words and look things up in
a [ __ ] dictionary it's also the
media's responsibility if you're going
to turn this into a [ __ ] circus which
is it is now become right and you invite
this lady on to good morning Brew you
can't just let it talk you've got a
Challenger what do you think that white
presenter at 7am in the morning yeah is
going to challenge a black woman who's
experienced a racial Vibe I would have
[ __ ] done it yeah how would you have
done it we've got the tax out for the
lads yeah and going oi and go to how the
[ __ ] is that abuse darling
well if you were wondering why Francis
does not co-present uh Good Morning
Britain at 7am on your TV uh that is one
of the many reasons why yeah thanks
Boxhead appreciate the Fiverr divinism
with the 1799. my brother was in the Sea
Cadets he attended the send-off on an
old carrier jet uh oh sorry no no
carries sorry maybe one of the Queens
helpers who asked him where he was from
that pause that you did after the
Queen's mate when met one of the Queens
oh help us yeah exactly I mean I bet
there's a lot of Queens in the Navy you
know what I'm saying I think so much
where is from and where he's really from
he's blonde and blue-eyed at 12 he was
more mature than her hmm
Paddington Mouse with the tennis says
the real question is doesn't gozi Fulani
like the chest of biscuits if if not she
should leave the UK
you know what to just I I have destroyed
many a British food yeah you have done
this rock slandered not slander
factually destroyed large slime and
resulting in numerous attempts to deport
me by a fan of trigonometry and you know
unfortunately none of them have worked
which just goes to show our immigration
system down the toilet really you can't
even Deport me for not liking the shitty
99 flake ice cream that is made out of
some chemical and served to you by a
slightly pedo looking Greek man anyway
that's you shouldn't talk about Anton
like that I told you mate he gets upset
it's never it's never anyone who looks
like Anton it's always a big sleazy
slobbering fat guy
with with like hair on his fingers
listen you've never seen Anton when he
comes back from the pub I've never seen
Anton fat mate no he has the the
deportation Chancellor back in the chat
people want to send me send me back but
anyway I've never actually had a problem
with digestive biscuits you know
really yeah they're decent Anton's
nodding he quite likes the digestive
what about you
see this is who we need to deport you
thought I was the secret weapon no no no
no no no no it's the Latino coming out
oh no no I don't like
do you know where it is or ever since I
gave up sugar I've just lost my desire
to eat biscuits and that stuff
just doesn't appeal to me
guys I think we got the fat [ __ ] out of
him then the people are you not a fat
[ __ ] anymore
no
it just doesn't appeal see fat shaming
works we told you we told you I was
looking after his health this whole time
look at him he's a he's a reformed man
he's slim he's healthy he's exercising
right [ __ ] broken and that's all down
to me
you were alone don't be nice to front no
fat shaming works
DBL says is FFL no he's finally healthy
just not happy yeah exactly mg
Constantine where are you going where
are you going to go back to where are
you going to go back to your Homeland I
can't go back to my homeland man they
don't like me anymore yeah after I
talked a lot of [ __ ] about Russia's
invasion of Ukraine yeah I can't you
have to keep me now Kim Jong I found it
very convenient we met you D assumes I'm
the person on the guest list with
non-british name faster service Spain
privilege thanks Kim Jong-un appreciate
it a Basha B with the two quitters are
you here for the diamonds very good
thanks Basha uh Aisha oh God
Revolution
it's from page because of the two Awards
bestowed on Harry and William in the U.S
I don't think that's where it's from
page I think it's front page because the
British media [ __ ] [ __ ] because
we're obsessed with rice thanks and the
Royal so you put those two together
speaking of people who are obsessed with
race yeah it's Vanessa from CCC kids I
thought you're going to say brand new
Smite I'm not don't introduce something
like that that would have been funny
who wants the great replacement anyway
yeah don't do that mate they're giving
us money
so is Vanessa C right let's do justice
too 70.
this is I am blunt in peel still get
asked where I'm from only team UK is
full of furnace it's perfectly
reasonable question and shows interest
in other people it's not so problematic
Vanessa that is absolutely true however
I will say given that you speak with
like accent like this it is Perfectly
Natural that people are equated from and
it's also a bit problematic having a
South African accent with the words UK
is full of foreigners does convey a
certain tone Vanessa
accent is beautiful in many ways but
particularly Berlin for expressing
racial Prejudice yeah Kim Jong BBC
shouldn't have announced like Queen
Death they pretty much did mate yeah
uh Sarah Sampson oh my god oh we met her
yesterday on the on that uh on our top
level support well second and top level
supporter call Purple Al not a clown how
do you need a rubber chicken or kazoo
after these kind of stories Sarah thank
you very much for that by the way
apparently now this is unverified so
we're just going to save a live around
hope we don't get sued uh and gozi's
real name is Mary Hedley
which would make sense because Caribbean
people tend to have anglicized names
whereas yeah of course
um so it might not even be her real name
so we'll shoot down then does she change
her name well it's like that Ibrahim X
candy his name is like Tony or something
Gary yeah Gary's about it's not Gary but
something he might as well be Gary yeah
I mean
Tim Charles my work have compulsory b i
e training I said no now I don't have to
do it this whole compulsory thing folds
at the slightest touch yeah but now
you're racist man you're probably not
going to get a promotion her parents are
from Barbados Barbados she's Beijing oh
[ __ ] beautiful part of the world mate
anyway next uh elytro if it was getting
annoying I would have just said I'm from
wakanda and moved on with my boring life
thanks that would have been really funny
actually or altas with 85. okay here we
go did you censor Sam Harris knew he
stepped in crap when your interview
wrapped in your parted ways
uh no no no not at all no I think he
walked out of there very comfortable
with how the interview went yeah
fod sakes thanks mate thanks mate uh Kim
Jong-un with a brown PM who else can
commentators accuse
well the pm has actually come out and
said racism blah blah blah blah blah of
course she would
uh Ricardo aguir Jr okay come on get the
Hat oh yes I mean he pretends to be
American but with a name like that come
on exactly no no it's wrong
oh my God well where he's really from
there you go
all right imagine if there is a guardian
I mean this is a gold mine
o I have not worked in 12 years and I
have jumped the world
[Laughter]
people who invite the whether you from
question are usually invite in the
question and usually can't wait to
answer it quite
thanks ricotta uh Patricia bottomly with
899 says do you have an accent for
someone from Shropshire and we can do a
generic West country that's about isn't
that Wales though was it next to Wales
yeah he's next to Wales yeah so they'd
still be infected with the accent no
it's I don't know is it it's West
country shops you're in it isn't it
Anton yeah yeah it's near Wells yeah but
it's that kind of Wales Bristol bit in
it yeah
no we don't as I think his answer okay
uh excuse me dears uh this is from blaby
blue sky uh old bird Mr Chancellor
respond to your mum heavens we could
have had the best your mum joke ever
good point thanks baby release I
appreciate the tenor uh Silas oh get the
Viking helmet yeah what does he say he
says ff's wizard is of a mall on 1980s
therapy it's a bit harsh man it's a
Fitbit [ __ ] blink that in it that's a
bit Bleak Jesus Christ mate he's lost a
bit of weight let's give him some
encouragement did you hear what he said
earlier he's not addicted to Sugar
anymore right we've we've exercised I am
like the Exorcist the fat shaming that
we did collectively over the last couple
of years right we we got the fat gun out
of them and it jumped out of a window
landed on a car and crushed it yeah and
he's left here
rather sad and unhappy looking a bit
definitely live a couple of years longer
exactly they won't be worth it it won't
be worth it but but he can he can
pretend to be healthy now
thank you anyways
interview with the South African home
Invader was absolutely chilling you
should look it up I'll do like a bit of
Louis through actually well he followed
us on Twitter so we'll drop him a little
messagio and if he doesn't come on we're
going to expose him that's what it's a
racist what's he done follows
trigonometry good point done sold uh
Matthew Heritage with the five says
remember when we used to laugh at this
shite now is just troubling when are we
going to turn the tide on this absolute
wank when is Peak wank coming yeah hey I
don't do you think there's a pequine
coming
every time I think there's a pea coin
because it's always easy yeah there's a
wank that's even more peaky
they speak Fair [ __ ] mate next enough
about your bedroom habits mate exactly
Eric Yuka with another five dollars what
you said just heard a British person
called Oreos chocolate sandwich biscuits
and I understand why the Revolutionary
War had to happen
do you like scenario tell me what yeah
like I said it's weird like I haven't
had sugar in a while and I was just
totally gone off it
don't I I think we broke Francis
what are we gonna do if I can't fact
shame you they used to be like half the
jokes yeah you did my it did yeah we
never thought it through I never thought
it would work it was just banter between
me and you yeah right no one got
offended you you know we'd finished the
show you'd go and have a couple of meals
afterwards yeah I'll go and have a
Chinese yeah everybody was happy do you
know what like now I've got this I don't
even have takeaways man really
we just went for a Turkish yeah but I
was in a takeaway mate I didn't even eat
the rice I just I salad with grilled
meat
true
and the guy came out I came this is the
true story you will be shocked by this
guy came up afterwards and he was like
guys you know you're coming here
regularly now uh I'm gonna give you uh
on the house uh you can share a banoffee
pie on the house and Francis went no
thank you
I don't know what's happening to me yeah
I think I'm Ill I nearly had a heart
attack I think I'm Ill I think that's it
I think I've contracted something like a
healthy lifestyle yeah this is what
happens when you hang around Anton long
enough it's like monkey pox yeah exactly
just get it yeah exactly even though you
don't want it
you just gets transmitted to you
before you know it you're infected in
your [ __ ] riddle Kathy kidson who
loves you so much he says look what
you've done cakey you've destroyed them
I have the only thing that made my life
worth you want to make an omelette
you've got to break a fat [ __ ] yeah I
can't don't drink anymore right because
I can't do that right
I've given up [ __ ] sugar can't do
that anymore right what do I eat for
[ __ ] dinner I had grilled meat and
salad
[ __ ] it that's worse than systemic
racism
I mean people are making the accurate
point in the chat that you could
identify as fat
that is true and then I'd be oppressed
yeah uh let's have let's have a look at
what Vanessa's saying she sent us
she says LOL I am English South African
not Africans different accent but Point
ticking let's when I say foreigners I do
include myself uh I I could see only
South African accent we can do I mean
let's be honest that's barely a South
African accent anyway so
um what accent would you have though uh
the South the Afrikaans is much because
obviously Afrikaans is a language right
and it's uh they originate from yeah
exactly that's [ __ ] learn English you
Dutch anyway uh so the the originates
from Holland so it's it's an Antiquated
version of Dutch Afrikaans right
um and then the English yeah right
exactly and so and then the English
Africa uh South Africans and the English
Africans don't like the south of the
Afrikaans no I mean I don't want to
lecture about the [ __ ] racial
tensions in South Africa I'm welcome I
mean yeah it's not the most well-known
place for racial integration I'm talking
about even the Whitestone you like each
other in there mate yeah and then and
then the mixed race people then there I
mean it's just a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
Minecraft says the the one Kiki is doing
is the if he can accent what about yours
to do in Africa certificate I am from
certificate I'm going to [ __ ] kill
you brew that's the same action isn't it
I've done I might that's actually what
I've uh a South African bloke started a
fight on me uh so I tried to fight me
about what 20 years ago now depressing
enough and those were his opening words
to me I'm going to [ __ ] kill you bro
it's a bit passive aggressive
maintenance it's quite active aggressive
yeah and then add brother at the end I'm
like
thanks Vanessa I appreciate it we're
going to keep doing these relaxing
because we can't do anything else all
right it is smiley Town ourself with the
499 says the cure for microaggressions
is a big healthy dose of shut up indeed
well said
uh fud sacks uh the anti-monicas Press
is still pissed off the death of the
queen didn't signal the end of the
monarchy they'll use any excuse to have
a gun well this is a good point because
it brings up something we haven't yet
talked about Francis you know what that
is well the Cowardly monarchy yeah
yeah absolutely but William threw her
under the bus yeah they got they forced
her to resign yeah they couldn't have
just said this was an unfortunate
misunderstanding we've taken steps for
reconciliation this uh ngozi person has
said she wants a positive outcome she
doesn't want the uh hussy to be uh
hounded I mean
you know there's a few flaws in that
argument mate I know I know but I'm just
saying they're they you know you know
why they did this if Megan doesn't
happen in the way that it's happened
this doesn't happen either yeah but no
this is just them throwing someone under
the bus to get the story
off the front pages they haven't even
done that yeah look and it's also as
well it's because of the woman because
of the woman if this woman was ex wasn't
Expendable if she was a you know a very
important it's just prince Andrew yeah
exactly she could probably get away with
that yeah and a lot more yeah exactly
because he wasn't systemic racing
because he only [ __ ] white girls yeah
so it makes you think doesn't it
it does
Progressive
yeah
were a bird she would be a tool oh but
luckily it's a strapping ladder than a
seven please send my warmers to Mrs
bottomley of shropship
you've got to do that in person mate
yeah
technology hasn't gone that far yeah uh
oh oh Tass 85 well the 499 says do you
guys look fondly at your time as child
actors on the set of Harry Potter
well I wasn't on the setup it's just him
mate yeah just me
I had nothing to do with it I want to
find JK rolling under the bus I would
have [ __ ] told you that much yeah
thanks though appreciate I appreciate
that uh Paddington mouse or the tenant
oi who say oi uh who says now to be
referred to as mpox your anti-month
monkey but anti-monkey bias he's
described is this true well yeah it's
referred to as Mbox now because I think
it's to destigmatize it and for it not
to be seen as I think because it's got
the word monkey in it it's seen as
racist I don't know what hmm
the one previous to the monkey pox was
supposed to be called the G virus I
believe but the who changed the who
changed at the request of the CCP it is
getting ridiculous now left to see
racism everywhere paranoid
you know look here's the thing right
if you are
if you contract monkey pox Francis no
I'm sorry I'm not going to listen to
this why I've had enough what
I've had enough what about what about
this world well I thought you're going
to say gay people that's relief no I've
got no problem with gay people yeah I've
got a problem with these [ __ ] yeah
gay people don't like twice either mate
some do the birds do the birds did but
the black's time
what was wrong with monkey pox what
what do you think you think if you
change the name the virus mutates into a
new version that's less lethal yeah
um
pox
it's called link to it and pox
do you know do you know what Tucker
Carlson calls it anymore covered
what is wrong with this world
I don't I don't like it
it's called monkey poke smite it's
racist
oh dear next all right uh Francis we
need to set a target for likes otherwise
we're gonna well how long we've done
we've done nearly now mate yeah so we
need to we've got uh 1100 people
watching which is fantastic yeah cool
let's get to 550 likes in the next uh so
that's another 200 basically in the next
five minutes and we will carry on with
the show so sure all right let's get
through some more Super chats and well
that's it well we've got a PayPal as
well well let's get the old PayPal up
mate Martin uh who I believe is German
yeah hussy should have given a clever
comeback like go back to Russia you [ __ ]
quoting one of my best bits of material
there thank you very much yeah
um and uh we had one more yeah from uh
the blues so just thought of the perfect
guest for some sanity Camilla
should I read this out I can't tell
yeah because that's a real person okay
who I don't know she is the former uh
Chief exec of a charity called kids
company who was then found to be doing
something dodgy with the funds right so
you're gonna say with the kids no
Camilla Batman
kids company it was a very famous case
kids company was a very big charity okay
I see
well Francis yeah do you know who would
never fiddle their account or their
children it's ground news everybody
that's it ground news sponsoring the raw
show today they are the best website if
you want to get an unbiased take on the
media stuff Anton pull it up go for it
uh this is our own feed and you can get
information about certain stories that
are happening and it will show you how
left and right-wing Publications are
covering the same story it also has a
blind spot feature so it shows you the
stories that the left-wing media aren't
covering and the right wing media I'm
covering so you can make up your own
mind and actually Francis uh what we
Sorry sure no so I so I was going to say
like they it's brilliant because it
helps you challenge your own assumption
and you're unbiased and we all have
viruses I don't have any buyers yeah and
yeah and see it helps to see the world
differently you can download the app for
free but I absolutely got it and start
seeing the world as it is or at least
our ground news is it so we've got a
creative feed and you can curate your
own one right so this is our curator
feed and what it does really
interestingly is you go to you can go to
a story so Anton let's please go to uh
the story that we talked about before
with muskie
so and you can see how the left are
reporting it and how the writer
reporting it oh so Anton so you see this
is a story that is almost exclusively
being covered by right leaning
Publications Anton if you scroll up a
little bit in the top right that says
total news sources 25 leaning left two
leaning right 18. so if you are left
leaning you probably haven't seen the
story and ground news will allow you to
do that and it does the same for people
who are right leaning it will show you
stuff that you otherwise wouldn't get to
see so this is a story uh which uh
right-ling people will probably be
familiar with which is Elon Musk says
Twitter failed trust and safety and
interfered in election something we've
covered extensively on the show with the
hunter Biden laptop story because we're
on the no we're not okay so scroll down
so Anton if we can just scroll down so
we've got it there and so you can see
all the Publications and uh which
Publications covered it and which didn't
and this is really important because if
you read certain Publications every
publication has a bias if you're if you
read a right leaning publication they're
going to have a bias and it's important
if you want to be across the news to
realize that actually you need a breadth
of Publications ground use is brilliant
for this download the app for free click
on the link it's in the description
and they're absolutely brilliant and we
use them here God bless ground news and
thank you to them for sponsoring the
show yeah so check it out if you haven't
already uh Anton let's get the remainder
of the Super Chat we've got a bunch that
uh flurry that came in and remember we
need to get to 550 likes in the next two
minutes if you want us to carry on with
the show for another half an hour or if
you don't if we don't get the likes of
that we take that as a sign that the
show hasn't been to your satisfaction
and then we'll wrap it up early so
entirely up to you we'll keep reading
the super chats as long as they're
coming in uh and uh as long as we've got
the likes we will carry on for another
half an hour Mr Steve please see the BBC
article on monkey box incredible and Mr
Steve if you could send it through to us
we've got it why don't we come back to
it let's let's catch up on the super
chats first yeah
uh Henrik Stevenson let's get some
Viking hat yes I'm never going to call
it n pox that's just racist who what the
hell
thanks Henrik thank you good to hear
from you mate Dave Somerset oh he's
gonna do a summership yeah he's American
but he's American Philadelphia cheers
from the Philadelphia area action wise
training you try and try to imitate late
comedian Dave Brenner don't know we
don't get paid enough keep up the good
work thanks Dave I really appreciate it
thank you so much good to have uh yet
another yank in the chat ah yeah yeah
because this is what they wear in Puerto
Rico
close enough fellas I'm Puerto Rican
Guatemalan and Salvadorian born and
raised in the bronc [ __ ]
mother effort I think is what he said
thank you very much Ricardo and I really
appreciate putting up with our casual
racism big fat Reddick uh with a two
quid uh says didn't the handsome brother
sing pox yes I did after they came out
hooligan Academy with a 449 good to have
someone from London in yeah Mike
rewarding private school fields and walk
rightness have you thought about sending
your kids to the holocan academy
guaranteed price of the hooligan Academy
yeah you can smash someone's face in
fantastic uh lady Shire with the 20s oh
this is this will be a lively gentle uh
female Vikings that does not sexual
assault you just kills you says now I
have um Bob on my mind except um pox
thank you KK Lovely Lady Shy thank you
very much Lorna's little Labs why have
you done that I don't know what the [ __ ]
is
I don't know but I'm doing it I don't
know why I don't know why okay
constantly I'm pretty sure she's
Portuguese man it's the same thing
if you're going to say oh God upon
seeing my name at least you could squeak
out a Debbie damn no intro I have no
idea what those words mean I have no
idea what you're talking about but but
yeah you're an attractive lady is that
this I'm confused Aisha I'm very happy
to see you or at least your Super Chat
uh guys yeah we need four more light a
Valerie Hull okay we need the American
hat again let's do this what if she says
is now I'm gonna have mbop in my head
all day by The Hansons thanks FF okay
we're basically given a bunch of people
music to think about yeah thanks Valerie
appreciate it Casey any thoughts on the
Infowars appearance other than this
default comparison to a car crash I
don't watch Infowars uh I watched uh
Kanye's appearance on uh Tim cast I
wrote a sub stack about that as well
which I thought was pretty spot on and
that was actually Tim and I talk about
this I liked him I respect him I think
he's built a great thing I frequently
wins when I see the guests that he has
on the show and I really once when I saw
him having Kanye Milo and especially
that Fuentes [ __ ] however it was a
perfect example of free speech working
they went on there they looked like a
bunch of [ __ ] they looked I mean
what kind you were saying and what the
others were attempting to support them
and was clearly racist he looked like a
racist well he's probably just mentally
ill to be honest
um and it was a victory for free speech
so well done to Tim I've got a slightly
different approach to it I think Kanye
is quite clearly very very mentally
unwell and I wish people around him
would advise him not to go on podcasts I
wish people who run big podcasts
wouldn't have him on nobody's interested
in what Kanye says it's a complete cargo
what do you mean no one's interested
millions of people are watching his
shirt
and what I mean is that the reason that
I said no one is interested people who
run podcasts aren't interested in what
Kanye has to say because he's a mentally
unwell man deeply deep okay well let me
challenge you on that if I may yeah may
I yeah did you want to make another
point right okay and the reason and what
happens is what we have is a 21st
century equivalent of a freak Show okay
so Joe Rogan who you and I both like
that respect he had Kanye on you think
Joe isn't interested in what county has
to say that was different because that
was a long time ago whereas this now is
he was a was it pretty then descendant
yes yeah years before oh was it yeah I
thought you had him on recently no it
was yeah fine what about Lex Friedman he
had him on post those comments to talk
about those comments you think Alex just
had him on as a freak Show
I think
so did he have him on as a freak Show I
think that's what you said yeah I think
at that point there might have been some
interest in having him on if I'm being
honest but at this point I don't think
there is any interest in having him on
so I should amend her I think at this
point now there is absolutely no worth
of value to be gained from having Kanye
West on I'd happily have him on I
wouldn't because I'd challenge him and
we'd have the conversation
that's why I'd have them on because the
the problem with with the approach and I
I get it it's like
he's talking to a huge audience of
people yeah whether you like it or not
yeah whether I like it or not yeah he's
speaking to a lot of people because
let's be clear he's a great very very
tired he's phenomenal yeah he's one of
the greatest talents of his generation
right so
that being the case
has a gigantic platform and he's saying
things the legitimately like need
interrogation they need to be challenged
yeah right so
either he he's allowed to just continue
to talk all the [ __ ] and he's got his
master platform or he comes in places
like Tim cars where he gets exposed for
what he is right
and in my opinion it's better to do that
than just let him continue spewing all
this crap in places where he's not going
to get challenged this is why I'm always
for the most part I mean obviously there
are limitations but for the most part in
favor of people being allowed to speak
because
in the right context like Tim cast was
yeah these people show themselves to be
what they are Kanye came out of that
looking very very bad as he should be
because what he was saying was genuinely
racist I see I agree with you apart from
when someone is soft clearly suffering
from a mental illness whereby they need
to be protected from themselves because
they're not fully in control of their
own actions but who who decides that
what if I what if you decide that I'm
mentally ill and I'm not well you don't
you haven't been diagnosed with type 2
bipolar which Kanye has okay so and he's
off his meds okay so okay so so but I'm
trying to what you're making very good
points by the way right however
so if someone is diagnosed with bipolar
does that mean they're not allowed to
talk in public
I mean when they're saying things that
are patently making no sense
good point and Nick Fuentes is a man who
makes a lot of sense don't [ __ ] clip
that it's been ironic but when some one
of these side effects of having bipolar
is and one of is when you're having an
episode is you believe is you have
delusions of grandeur number one so he
said he's running for president and
number two is you see and think I mean
you can't you can't stop anyone who
wants to run this person from speaking
in the public yeah but but I think he
talks about how God has done this for
him right so yeah okay and the second
thing is is what you have is that you
see and believe things that uh that you
think things that exist that don't exist
essentially and you can and they come in
the form of either you believe certain
things or you have hallucinations or you
see things and I believe when somebody
is having gone through a severe manic
episode which Kanye has and he has a
diagnosed mental illness I believe it is
a responsibility of other people to see
that and realize that this is a man who
is fundamentally unwell
and protect him from himself right but
in addition to he I understand your
concern for him yeah and I share it by
the way because I don't think he's well
on the other hand if someone of his
stature is saying these things in public
there needs to be a robust discussion
and Challenge and the only way to do
that is to bring him onto a platform
where he will be challenged yeah
otherwise he's going to go on places
where they're just going to let him
ramble yeah and that's what's going to
happen so who is it that has the
responsibility to step in he's clear I
don't think he's married no he's
divorced sadly in fact his wife came out
and actually said he's bipolar and
please show him compassion because he's
a very old man
okay well this is where you sort of come
into okay well someone can be bipolar
and be going around murdering people
yeah I think we will like showing
compassion well no their actions have
consequences words because of who he is
have consequences right so it doesn't
need to be addressed in some way so if
his wife is not there and I imagine I
don't know much about bipolar but I
imagine if someone's having some kind of
episode they're probably not going to
listen to their wife no I mean they
probably wouldn't listen if they're not
having a manic episode
right so who who are these people that
are supposed to step in and look after
him the people around him he's advisors
Nick Fuentes and malianopolis well this
is this is the exact point because
what's happened is then the vultures are
starting to Circle in the form of Milo
and Nick Fuentes now I have never met
either but I think we can ascertain
they're not good faith actors they are
essentially right I agree with you so
right totally so who is who is this
person that's supposed to step in that
you're talking about
so I'm saying that it would be that the
people around him the people who are his
team not Milo and and Fuentes and all
these [ __ ] reprehensible individuals
I should be there but who is that
it's probably his former Jewish man that
he's upset told him to apparently told
him to take his meds and he went [ __ ]
nuts well is that what happened this is
anyway so my point overall is this I
don't understand who it is that's
supposed to be telling him where to go
and what and I don't think he's
particularly controllable judging by no
his actions no I imagine that's part of
what mental illness like this creates
yes so
if that being the case
if he's going to keep talking in public
and we've established there's no way to
stop him yeah I do think the
responsibility on people like Tim and
Rogan and Lex and people like us and
whatever is to address the comments that
he's making
right because the comments he's making
will have an impact on people thinking
about things right
so from that perspective I understand I
understand what you're saying he should
be protected by himself I just don't see
who should be doing that and therefore I
think it's more about the impact his
words are having on the rest of society
they need to be debated they need to be
challenged they need to be shown to be
what they are he needs to be shown to be
what he is which is someone who's not
well and someone who's saying things
that are racist yeah
I think at this point we all but my
point is I think at this point that we
all know he's deeply and fundamentally
unwell okay
I don't see I I don't see the value if
I'm being honest on getting a man who is
clearly suffering who is clearly unwell
and getting him to ramble about nonsense
no but that's not why I would get him on
I'd get him on to challenge the things
that he's saying yeah about Jewish
people and about other groups and
whatever yeah
and his deliberate conflation of things
that that's causing this issue yeah
that's why I wouldn't get him on to talk
about you know how he sees things or God
or whatever talk to him about what he's
saying and go you're saying this but
have a think about this or let's look at
it like that or whatever yeah to me like
I see no real difference with what he's
saying in a way with it's just it's just
the paranoid delusions of a
deeply unwell man and a lot I'm not his
comments are on they're disgusting
they're anti-semitic they're awful
to me it's a manifestation of an illness
well you know there's people in the chat
going well you know all you do is
strengthen his argument by silence him I
mean his argument is basically the Jews
of con they control entertainment so
they've silenced me and then he gets
silenced
stupid people admittedly but there's a
lot of them in the world they're going
to go oh it proves it's important yeah
I just look and part of this is just to
me is tinged with sadness because I just
see the suffering of a human being I
agree that type of mental illness like
we bang on about a minute to do all the
time but that you wouldn't want you
wouldn't wish that on your worst enemy
what that was of course not of course
not but my point is to you is you you're
right but that is the case but the fact
is he's going to keep talking in public
am I wrong
I mean he's got a gigantic Twitter
account he could take his phone out and
record whatever [ __ ] he wants and
put it on Twitter yeah so how is that
different
you're not you're not restricting him
you know and you're not helping him no I
I don't see what good it does to bring
him on and
talk to a man who is clearly not in full
control of his faculties
you challenge the stuff that he's saying
for other people to see that is [ __ ]
oh and maybe maybe he's got some valid
points about certain things as well I
don't know but that's how you yeah
that's how that's how you do it right
yeah
you know what I mean yeah I guess we'll
have to agree to disagree on this one I
actually don't think we disagree I think
we're just talking about different
aspects yeah yeah maybe we are maybe we
are and I just I find I just find it and
as well look I'm more emotional and like
I just I just see this person who is
deeply unwell suffering and then you get
these horrible little pathetic vultures
in Milo and Friends well we agree you
know deliberately piggybacking on on him
and then sitting there and
anyway Casey thank you very much uh you
sparked quite a conversation as you can
see
what's he say he says I nailed the chick
from Hinson yes
what chick from Hansen uh it's a joke
because they're all men
oh okay I don't know what that refers to
but they were a boy band they had like
two hits okay
um ah that's the one okay cool gotcha
gotcha uh Minecraft ideally someone with
bipolar would receive support instead of
a loudspeaker egged on by sycophantic
hangers or making the most of the
spectacle yeah I agree Anton I think we
skipped over a few super chats I
remember seeing at least one from Laura
earlier than that one from Mycroft can
you just make sure we don't want to you
know I know Francis and I were banging
on we've got one from Anonymous and he
was the one after Joseph Yasin one
there's a couple that you missed out
uh could you uh find them if you could
please and in the meantime I'll uh we've
got a couple of paypals as well
if my phone would stop [ __ ] about
sorry about this guys
yeah go for it Silas Larson okay so he
says Kanye is useful as he exposes
ideological beliefs that many
African-Americans have indulged for
decades due to societal protection of
their prejudices
I mean I I think it's fair to say that
anti-Semitism is quite a good place in
the in the African-American Community or
in the black community yeah
um was that african-americ I don't know
it's hard to say but but it's quite
prevalent and uh I have some theories
about why but we won't get into into
them tonight thanks Silas I appreciate
the 4.99 uh Hannah sent us two quid says
M pox some fun some flu it's all inside
this Happy Meal is that song lyrics that
I've butchered that have been repurposed
and Peter with a four chord says KK Tim
had yay on hoping to have a conversation
and look what he got that's the convo
you would get good
good I mean it the part of the the
process of freedom of expression is you
communicate with people and this is what
we do on the show we bring people on to
talk to them about and give them an
opportunity to show who they really are
right
and David packman did that yep smashed
it and most other guests on our show
have done that in one way or another now
we are very careful generally to pick
out people who we think are gonna offer
something of value to you rather than
someone who's going to come on and be a
dick or try to make us look like a dick
but every now and again I think it's
good to bring someone on with whom you
disagree and challenge their opinions
particularly if they've got you know a
big platform on which they're saying
what they're saying I don't want to
silence them I want to show the world
what how this person thinks and with
Kanye when I watch that Temple thing it
was very clear that this is a guy who is
not thinking very clearly but at the
same time making some very serious
allegations that are clearly racist yeah
right so
uh that's why I I felt that way anyway
Anton have we got those other super
chats now yeah let's do it uh
okay Anna moose oh my God anonymous
anonymous that's a great pun
Francis I expect you to start taking
Royce get big and skinny shame
Constantine you know I'm gonna be like
that fisher king what's his name liver
King the liver King yeah yeah thanks and
we've got one from Laura as well it says
I get the flat cap mate come on okay
properly all right [ __ ] yes
I haven't worked in 12 years and worked
in 12 years hang a monkey I'm a monkey
man being mentally unwell does not make
you anti-semitic it I disagree with that
actually I think uh one of the signs of
some mental illness is a conspiratorial
world view and a conspiratorial world
view there are a lot of conspiracy
theories about Jews uh although there's
a lot of conspiracy theories about many
groups but about Jews as well uh and so
I think it can make you anti-semitic
actually if you buy into a lot of
conspiracies eventually you're going to
run across some that are anti-semitic
and if you believe them you're going to
end up in this position yeah
great thanks Laura
Silas Larson oh no we've had this one
yes yeah we have uh Terry knee with the
ten dollars says Churchill was bipolar
what I didn't know that
um
it might well be I don't I'm slandering
our greatest Britain mate there's
different types of look the leader was
[ __ ] mental the lady was [ __ ]
means
[ __ ] right look there's a lot of very
talented very intelligent very
successful people who are bipolar and
there are different types of bipolar and
like a lot of mental illnesses they
manifest in different ways
um so he might well have been I don't
know
thank you thanks Tony
Frank Booth for the Fiverr storm is
admission to kissing a Tory raises more
questions than it answers
how far did he go has he popped his Tory
cherry and would he be forgiven
I didn't know this well Starman admitted
I mean I told you the spectator
parliamentarian Awards he talked all
about how he loves the Battle of ideas
not not the festival but yeah you know
the concept so maybe he's not everything
he's been made up to be yeah mate we'll
see thanks Frank appreciate it Kim
Jong-un uh invites him to chat in the
you enough why am I talking invite him
to chatting UK then get him sectioned
good plan Kim Jong-un appreciate it
thank you and talk himara with the two
questions KK will never call out a right
winger
that's not true
I've called Francis how many yeah
exactly boom and I'm a right winger
did he mean right wing Joe did he mean
right winger I don't know didn't I I'm
imagining Kanye's not on the woke left
no and I've just called him out I've
called that right when he's all the time
mate what are you talking about or right
Wingers I don't know of course what EVs
mate is that everything Anton let's go
to the Empire story that's what I want
to see we all want a bit of [ __ ]
inbox in our life mate no we don't mate
I want the full monkey pox full monkey
let's do the full monkey monkey pox uh
give a new name by global Health experts
there is
monkeypox will now be known as empocs
though the who has announced after
complaints over racist and stigmatizing
language linked to the virus's name the
old term will be used alongside the new
one for a year because we're okay with
racism for a year uh before being phased
out empox was decided on after lengthy
discussions between experts countries
and the Gen I don't remember being
consulted about this apparently the
general public were involved though mate
carry on yeah it can easily be used in
English as well as other language the
who said human monkey pox was first
identified in 1970 and named after the
disease caused by the virus was
discovered in captive monkeys more than
a decade before since then the who has
introduced advice uh I can't see the top
of them
on naming diseases it stresses the need
to minimize unnecessarily negative
impact on trade travel tourism or animal
welfare and to avoid causing offense to
any culture natural social National or
ethnic groups during the covert pandemic
it recommended that variants were
referred to using letters of the Greek
alphabet because they were
non-stigmatizing and easy to pronounce
this year there has been unusual spread
of empox virus a member of the same
violent family of viruses as smallpox in
many countries outside Central and West
Africa where it is often found why have
we not renamed smallpox to normal sized
pox so it's not offended yeah exactly
disgusting in July the who decaded
Global Health Emergency for the 65th
time that year because of the worldwide
surge in people developing symptoms
including a high fever and skin lesions
or rash
watch Dan spoke about his ex
sorry we can't see the top of the screen
man so just
yeah I know he he spoke about his
experience of Contracting monkey pox
anyway cases of the disease have been
declining for several months thanks to
the renaming but more than a hundred
different countries have been affected
in 2022 prompting huge demand for
vaccine supplies to protect those at
most risk now who would that be
the U.S Brazil Spain France and the UK
have reported the highest total number
of impulse cases this year globally
there have been 50 deaths from the virus
since May the UK has reported more than
three and a half thousand cases but a
number of vaccines to vulnerable groups
helped drive down numbers following a
peak in July most people were affected
with blokes who love shagging blokes
there we go there we go mate so it's
been renamed to avoid offending monkeys
exactly and they won't have that in uh
Hartlepool or Newcastle exactly [ __ ]
angle man hanging man I'm gonna buy
their [ __ ] bulls I don't know what
went wrong with that
actions
there we go mate well Francis yes uh we
have a little clip because we've been
talking seriously for a long time yeah
about the way the main I mean we talked
a lot about how the media cover things
we've got a little clip which shows you
how they how they come up with the
headlines this is absolutely brilliant
have a look at this
foreign
[Laughter]
Works God bless him good bloody bless
him right we've got a few minutes left
we've got probably got some bigots in
the old Super Chat yo let's bring it up
we haven't got any you type Boston
what's wrong with you send us money no
it's a [ __ ] describe you guys have
been great uh so far by the way reminder
if you're not already on locals locals
as well all the cool stuff happens it's
also the best way to support the show uh
studio is nearly finished we are hoping
to be recording in here properly in
about 10 days time and it's basically
tripled our studio cost because this is
a bigger space and blah blah blah so if
you want to support the show if you want
to make it possible if you enjoy raws if
you enjoy our interviews please do join
locals it's also a really fun community
of like-minded people uh by the way I
don't think we have this clip but one of
our fans uh Ali Snyder she is a clip of
her talking at her think it was at her
school board meeting in California it's
gone pretty viral I retweeted it a Colin
Wright initially posted it and a bunch
of people have retweeted it and um uh
she she's she's basically it's amazing
for us to see someone who uh you know
watches our show uh you know just going
out in the world and saying what she
thinks and making an impact in her local
community and that then becoming a story
is absolutely brilliant and that's the
sort of people that you have there so uh
good good on you ali uh great to see
that happening for you and uh yeah join
Ali and everybody else in in in having
fun on our locals yeah it's a great
place to meet to hang out to share memes
to get incredible extra content WE Post
we're always on there as well doing a
bit of back and forth on the old banter
so it's a great place to be check it out
and plus you get to make all this
sorry the link is in the description as
Anton says Francis uh is there a story
you wanted to talk about today there's
lots of stories that I was looking to
talk about mate we put a lot of funny
ones in well why don't we do a funny one
before we wrap up mate yeah I think
that'd be a good one just reading all
the chat which is also very funny keep
it going okay so let's talk about
Boxhead a center survive hasn't he or
yeah yeah we've got a couple actually
let's let me do the Super Chat while she
picks out a story Boxhead thank you very
much for the Fiverr and I think we had
another one from Kim uh Patricia
bottomley with the 449 says love locals
and my love to Mr Larson yeah that is
what he wants the good old Viking Kim
Jong-un with the 449 says go and throw a
severe mental health crisis is like
psychosis does show you how reluctant
people are to intervene in other serious
psychological yeah I mean it's like
Francis I mean I know the point he's
making and it's a good point however how
do you help someone who's got bipolar
do you know well do with someone like
that I I don't know like my wife can't
get me to behave when I'm just a bit
grumpy you know what I'm serious yeah
right it's a good look it's a good point
you're making the reason that this is a
very tough discussion because we like to
bang on about mental health when we like
to talk about the easy stuff but things
like this it's you know it requires a
conversation right yeah Mental Health
Mate meanwhoof
uh anyway uh let's talk about the story
that you picked up okay so that leads to
people often go to me Francis what was
it like growing up with a Latin American
mother in a Latin American house there
is this video sums up what it's like
growing up with a Latino mum better than
any other video I've ever seen check
this out
thank you
when I thought of this hello good
afternoon good afternoon I
mean
yes your name is not Moon okay well this
sounds pretty foreign
Colombiana
foreign
yo Entre
you know what I was thinking all
throughout that she's [ __ ] else she's
a bit full-on but it works yeah at the
end of it she was like yeah bachelor in
mothers they're all all these people
here were just like that's funny how do
I control it
and I love the way she was like saying
my name is Moon and even the program the
[ __ ] Chiron was like Luna yeah
espanol and she what was really funny
didn't understand it she went she went
uh where are you from she was like I I
am from America no where are you really
from Colombia so you're in Colombia
and I love the way within about like two
two she denied her twice and by the
second one the third time she was like
just leaning over the desk that's funny
hard I'm telling you mate they cannot be
denied you [ __ ] listen people go like
oh I my mum was strict get to [ __ ]
you've never seen that [ __ ] hell well
me uh if if nothing else it kind of
explains a lot yeah
God bless you if you're wondering why
he's a bit mental yeah you've just had a
little a little sneak peek into a
childhood that's when I didn't finish my
dinner mate
hahaha
all right well on that very uh funny but
sad story about France's childhood I
think we best wrap up ladies and
gentlemen I think we will agree with us
that that was a [ __ ] brilliant role
yeah thank you so much for joining us
it's been an absolute pleasure we are
back tomorrow with another raw like this
one uh make sure you're on locals for
notice of upcoming interviews ask your
questions of our guests join the
community we really appreciate all your
support have yourselves a great day a
great evening and we will see you same
time tomorrow
have funny all